Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue dans une nouvelle vidéo.
Aujourd'hui, j'avais envie de vous faire un podcast dans lequel je vous raconte
comment j'ai fini tout nu au Japon.
Alors, dans ce podcast, je vais parler de plusieurs choses, mais du coup, je
vais arriver à vous parler de cette histoire que j'ai eue au Japon.
Comme vous le savez peut-être, je m'intéresse à la culture japonaise et
j'apprends le japonais, c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle je suis devenu
professeur de français.
C'est que j'ai pris goût à l'apprentissage des langues, j'aime apprendre le
japonais et ça m'a donné envie de moi-même enseigner le français.
Et du coup, depuis 2020, depuis mon premier voyage au Japon, je suis
allé au
Japon trois fois.
Et en fait, à travers ces voyages, j'ai pu observer les différences culturelles
entre la France et le Japon.
Même si c'est des pays occidentaux, on va dire le Japon, c'est un pays
asiatique, mais il y a une très forte influence américaine, culturellement,
c'est hyper différent.
Et il y a juste à voir la différence entre par exemple, Paris et Tokyo, vous
prenez le métro à Paris, vous prenez le métro à Tokyo et c'est le jour et la
nuit.
À Tokyo, les gens sont très discrets, les japonais sont très discrets, ils
respectent les règles, c'est l'image qu'on a des japonais.
Et par exemple, quand on est arrivé pour la première fois à l'aéroport, on
voyait les gens qui faisaient la queue pour monter dans l'escalator, qui
faisaient la queue pour monter dans le train.
Et ça, c'était assez surprenant parce qu'à Paris ou en France de manière
générale, personne ne fait ça.
J'ai travaillé 5 ans à Paris, tous les matins, je prenais le métro et on jouait
des coudes pour monter dans le train, c'est-à-dire qu'on poussait avec les
coudes pour être le premier à monter dans le train, donc c'est une autre
ambiance.
Dans cette vidéo, je vais parler des différences culturelles, je veux bien sûr
préciser que ce n'est pas forcément mieux ou moins bien.
Forcément, quand on parle de cette discipline des japonais, de ce respect des
règles, on peut se dire que c'est forcément mieux qu'en France, mais en France,
les individus, les personnes sont peut-être plus libres individuellement, donc
c'est vraiment un très gros débat.
Et je ne suis pas du tout là pour parler de ce débat, je suis plutôt là pour
parler des différences de manière un peu amusante, on va dire.
Et du coup, tout de suite, quand on arrive au Japon et qu'on voit ça, on se dit
Wow, c'est vraiment, les gens sont respectueux, dans le train, personne ne
parle, c'est calme, les gens, ils peuvent s'endormir avec leurs téléphones
portables dans la main en Europe, en France, au moins à Paris
Je ne vous le conseille pas trop et du coup, c'est vrai qu'on se dit Wow,
c'est
vraiment impressionnant, pareil, dans la rue, personne ne se touche, personne ne
se cogne les épaules, Tokyo, il y a énormément de monde et pourtant, personne ne
vous bouscule quand vous marchez dans la rue.
Et les seuls fois où quelqu'un m'a un peu touché l'épaule, la personne s'est
tout de suite retournée en faisant la courbette et en s'excusant, en disant "Ah,
sumimasen, gomennasai", et du coup, ça, c'est très
impressionnant parce qu'à Paris, quand vous tapez l'épaule contre
quelqu'un,
c'est limite si vous vous retournez, vous n'avez pas envie de vous embrouiller
avec la personne.
Donc, c'est vrai que c'est une posture, c'est une société complètement
différente, avec des points négatifs aussi, je pense, mais on n'est pas là pour
parler de ça.
Il y a cette différence culturelle et il y a aussi une grosse différence qui est
la mixité.
Au Japon, il y a très peu de mixité, c'est-à-dire que tous les Japonais, je vais
faire un cliché, mais tous les Japonais ont les cheveux bruns, raides, alors
qu'en France, vous pouvez être une personne noire, une personne aux traits asiatiques,
une personne blanche, peu importe, tout le monde est français finalement, et
comme il y a cette mixité, on est beaucoup plus habitué, entre guillemets, à ce
que ce soit normal tout simplement.
Alors qu'au Japon, nous, moi par exemple avec ma tête de blanc, je n'ai jamais
été considéré comme un Japonais tout simplement parce qu'il y a très peu de
mixité, et du coup, ça se voit que je ne viens pas du Japon.
En France, dire à quelqu'un "Ah toi tu n'es pas français parce que t'as l'air
asiatique", c'est raciste, donc ça on ne le dit pas tout simplement parce qu'il
y a une mixité qui fait qu'en fait, il y a des Français de tout type.
Et du coup, ça c'est, en fait pourquoi je parle de ça, c'est parce qu'au Japon,
du coup, on peut se retrouver dans des situations un peu impressionnantes en
tant que touristes, c'est-à-dire que par exemple, pendant un an avec ma femme,
on a voyagé au Japon, et quand on sortait des lieux touristiques, quand on
sortait de Tokyo, Kyoto, quand on allait à la campagne notamment, on voyait que
les gens n'étaient pas du tout, et enfin, étaient moins habitués à voir des
étrangers.
Et forcément, c'était écrit sur notre tête qu'on n'était pas Japonais, et par
exemple, une fois on était chez la grand-mère d'une amie à Kagoshima,
c'est une
ville tout au sud de l'île de Kyushu, on est allé au supermarché, et là, je me
rappelle, il y avait des enfants qui, quand ils m'ont vu, ils m'ont regardé
comme ça, ils m'ont dit "Oh, qu'est-ce qu'il fait là lui ?" C'était un peu ça.
C'était amusant, personnellement, je n'ai jamais vécu de racisme direct au
Japon, mais c'était amusant de voir comme ça cette surprise sur les visages des
enfants, je pense que les adultes étaient peut-être aussi surpris, mais que du
coup, peut-être par politesse, ils ne le montraient pas, mais en tout cas, les
enfants, eux, ils étaient vraiment surpris.
On a eu ça, et après, par exemple, à Kagoshima, là, avec notre amie, on est allé
dans des bains publics, par exemple, et moi, je me suis retrouvé avec 30
Japonais, tout seul chez les hommes, le seul blanc, et c'était assez
impressionnant.
Pareil, dans une ville qui s'appelle Fukui, mais même dans d'autres endroits du
Japon, on est allé au restaurant, et là, vous ouvrez la porte du restaurant, et
vous voyez que des Japonais, personne ne parle anglais, et c'est impressionnant
parce que vous rentrez, et vous voyez que les gens vous regardent un peu en mode
"Oh, un étranger !"
Et du coup, on a un peu, voilà, on ne marche pas sur des oeufs, mais c'est vrai
qu'on se sent quand même étrangers, et que c'est impressionnant d'avoir comme ça
un peu ce regard sur nous, un peu ce regard interrogateur sur nous.
Et donc ça, c'est quand même une grosse différence, parce que je pense qu'en
France, bon, à Paris, par exemple, on peut facilement dire qui est touriste,
parce que après, il y a l'attitude aussi.
Si vous êtes dans les rues de Paris, et que vous cherchez votre chemin, et que
vous regardez tout autour de vous, il y a des chances pour que vous soyez un
touriste, mais je veux dire, à part ça, à part l'attitude, on ne peut pas
savoir.
Au Japon, oui, et du coup, parfois ces expériences culturelles, on va dire,
elles sont super intéressantes, mais parfois un peu impressionnantes, et
notamment une en particulier, et c'est le sujet de cette vidéo.
Au Japon, il y a une culture des bains publics. Alors, dans le monde, on connaît
surtout les onsen, qui sont des sources d'eau chaude naturelle, parce que
forcément, au Japon, il y a énormément de volcans, donc il y a beaucoup de
sources d'eau chaude naturelle, et du coup, il y a beaucoup de onsen, les onsen,
par exemple, vous voyez, dans les animés, les mangas, etc.
Et il y a aussi les sento qui ont différencié les sento, c'est plus les
bains publics. Donc, par exemple, dans Tokyo, vous pouvez avoir des
bâtiments
comme ça, ou vous pouvez aller prendre votre bain, enfin, aller aux bains
publics.
En France, on n'a pas du tout cette culture.
Je pense que peut-être en Europe, on a cette culture peut-être en Allemagne,
dans les pays scandinaves, une culture du sauna, peut-être.
Mais en tout cas, en France, c'est vraiment quelque chose de très rare, et du
coup, quand on va au Japon, on se dit que c'est quand même une
expérience assez
unique à faire, d'aller dans des bains publics.
C'est unique, mais en même temps, c'est assez impressionnant parce que qui dit
aller aux bains publics, dit se mettre tout nu avec plein d'autres personnes, et
ça, c'est pas quelque chose qu'on a l'habitude de faire, je pense, en France.
Personnellement, j'ai fait un sport collectif, pendant longtemps, j'ai fait du
hockey sur glace, de mes 7 ans à mes 18 ans.
Donc, de mes 7 ans à mes 18 ans, très régulièrement, je prenais la douche avec
tous mes copains de l'équipe, et du coup, voilà, j'avais un peu cette habitude
de sorte de bains publics.
Donc, même si j'étais habitué à ça, je pense qu'en France, on a une certaine
pudeur physique.
La pudeur, c'est pas de la timidité, mais ça se rapproche de la timidité,
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'aime pas forcément montrer quelque chose, montrer notre
corps, par exemple.
Quelqu'un de pudique, c'est quelqu'un qui n'aime pas montrer son corps, ou il y
a aussi une pudeur émotionnelle, quelqu'un de pudique, ça peut être quelqu'un
qui n'aime pas montrer ses émotions.
Et en fait, c'est marrant, parce que j'ai l'impression que la France, c'est le
Japon, c'est complètement l'opposé.
La France, on va avoir un peu une pudeur physique, on va être plus pudique quand
il faut montrer notre corps, entre guillemets, par exemple, aller au bain public
et prendre un bain tout nu avec 20 autres personnes qu'on ne connaît pas.
Ça peut paraître un peu bizarre, et par contre, on n'est pas du tout pudique
d'un point de vue des émotions.
En France, voilà, vous pouvez faire votre déclaration d'amour, etc. Vous pouvez
faire ça en pleine rue, c'est pas choquant.
Et en fait, j'ai l'impression qu'au Japon, c'est tout à fait l'inverse,
c'est-à-dire que prendre un bain tout nu avec n'importe qui, ce n'est pas un
problème.
Quand on était en colocation avec ma femme, on allait souvent au bain public
avec nos colocataires, et voilà, c'était normal pour eux, pour les Japonais,
c'était normal pour les Japonais.
Et pareil, dans tous les bains où je suis allé, c'était vraiment une activité
normale.
Et par contre, parler de ces émotions au Japon, je crois, je pense savoir que
c'est un peu compliqué, enfin que du moins ils sont très pudiques au niveau des
émotions.
C'est-à-dire que parfois, d'ailleurs, on peut avoir le sentiment qu'il y a un
peu une façade, il y a un terme en japonais qui est le tatemae, qui est un peu
la façade pour les autres.
Et du coup, parfois, on a un peu l'impression d'être un peu que les Japonais
cachent un peu leurs émotions.
Et je trouvais ça intéressant, puisque du coup, d'un côté, il n'y a pas du tout
cette pudeur physique, mais du coup, par contre, de l'autre, il y a une grosse
pudeur émotionnelle.
Un exemple que j'ai en tête, c'est Terrace House.
Terrace House, c'est une téléréalité japonaise que je regarde en ce moment sur
Netflix.
En gros, c'est une téléréalité où il y a trois hommes et trois femmes qui vivent
ensemble dans une maison.
Et l'idée, c'est de faire qu'ils aient des histoires d'amour, ils ont des
objectifs professionnels, ce genre de choses.
Une téléréalité classique, sauf que là, à la japonaise, c'est assez différent
quand même, c'est beaucoup moins direct.
Quand ils essaient d'avoir des histoires de coeur, des histoires d'amour,
c'est
vraiment, c'est long et c'est beaucoup de discussions.
Et du coup, c'est intéressant parce qu'ils ont du mal, enfin, c'est pas qu'ils
ont du mal.
Ce n'est pas forcément une difficulté, mais disons qu'ils ne montrent pas
directement leurs émotions, je pense.
Alors qu'en France, ça serait beaucoup plus naturel de faire comme ça.
Et oui, non et pardon, et je reviens au bien public, mais dans cette
téléréalité,
tous ils prennent, enfin, les hommes et les femmes séparément, mais ils ont
cette habitude de prendre le bain ensemble.
Et ce n'est pas du tout quelque chose d'anormal.
Donc ça, je trouve ça très intéressant.
Et du coup, maintenant, si je relis les deux points, donc la différence en
termes de mixité et la différence au niveau de la pudeur, de la pudeur physique
notamment,
eh bien, ça m'amène à cette expérience que j'ai eue au Japon qui est
l'expérience des bains publics.
Comment j'ai fini par être tout nu au Japon ?
Bon, le titre, je vous l'accorde, tout nu dans un bain, je n'étais pas tout nu
en pleine ville, bien évidemment.
Mais je voulais vous parler du coup de la première fois où je suis allé dans un
bain public.
C'était pendant mon deuxième voyage au Japon et en fait, pendant mon premier
voyage, je n'y étais pas allé.
Je pense que j'avais pas peur, mais j'étais un peu en mode non, non, c'est bon.
En plus, comme je voyageais avec ma femme et notre amie japonaise,
forcément, je
suis le seul homme, ça veut dire que de mon côté, je vais aller tout seul au
bain, c'est séparé.
Et du coup, je vais être tout seul de mon côté, donc je n'avais pas trop envie.
Le deuxième voyage, on est partis avec ma femme, ses parents, sa tante, sa sœur
et le mari de sa sœur, donc mon beau frère, mon beau frère,
my brother-in-law.
On y est allé et j'ai commencé à essayer de motiver un peu les troupes, on va
dire, pour aller au bain public.
Parce que là, je me disais, bon, c'est la deuxième fois, j'ai manqué cette
expérience qui est une expérience unique et j'avais envie d'y aller, mais je
préférais ne pas y aller tout seul.
J'ai essayé de motiver les troupes et mon beau frère voulait aussi aller essayer
les bains publics, donc on y est allé ensemble.
On y est allé ensemble à Kyoto et il y avait un bain public pas très loin de la
gare.
Une particularité, c'est que les tatouages au Japon sont mal vus, mais de
manière générale, dans les sentos, dans les bains publics, vous pouvez y aller
avec des tatouages.
C'est beaucoup plus restrictif dans les onsen, dans les sources d'eau
chaude naturelle.
Et du coup, mon beau frère, il a des très gros tatouages, et du coup, j'ai
regardé sur Internet, il disait que c'était ok pour venir avec des tatouages, et
du coup, on s'est dirigé vers le bain public.
Quand on est arrivé, il y avait deux entrées, du coup, il y avait une entrée
homme, une entrée femme, et en fait, quand on rentrait dans le bâtiment, c'était
un très vieux bâtiment, il y avait une accueil commune aux deux côtés, en fait.
Cet accueil, il y avait une vieille dame, et du coup, on est rentrés, et voilà,
j'ai demandé à la dame, est-ce que c'est ok, les tatouages, etc.
Elle nous a dit oui, etc.
Et là, c'est là où ça a commencé à devenir un peu compliqué, parce que,
déjà que
quand on va dans un restaurant où il n'y a que des Japonais, on peut être un peu
gêné, un peu stressé, en mode comment est-ce qu'il faut faire, etc.
Mais là, dans un bain public, c'est la même chose, mais tout nu.
Du coup, j'avais un peu regardé, donc on commence à mettre nos chaussures dans
des casiers.
On arrive dans une espèce d'entrée, et là, en fait, c'est l'endroit où tout le
monde se déshabille.
Ah oui, d'ailleurs, et ce que je n'ai pas dit, c'est que quand on est rentrés
dans le bain, quand on a ouvert la porte, direct, on a vu la salle où tout le
monde se déshabille, où tous les hommes se déshabillaient, et du coup, là,
direct, on a ouvert la porte, on a fait "ok".
Et donc, on range nos chaussures, et là, on commence à se déshabiller, et sauf
qu'il y avait des casiers, donc les casiers, c'est les boîtes pour ranger nos
affaires.
Et il y avait des très grosses clés en bois, c'était des vieux casiers, et sauf
qu'on n'arrivait pas à fermer, du coup, on était tout nu comme ça, en train
d'essayer de fermer.
Et on demandait à la dame de l'accueil, mais bon, comme c'était une dame, elle
n'osait pas trop regarder à nous dire "ah non, comme ça", et nous, on était tout
nu à essayer de fermer le casier, c'était assez marrant.
Et du coup, après, on va vers le bain, mais là, pareil, on se dit "est-ce qu'il
faut prendre une serviette ?" "est-ce qu'il faut prendre du savon ?" "est-ce
qu'il faut prendre..." et du coup, voilà, un peu stressé.
On prend notre serviette, la dame nous dit "non, laissez-les à l'entrée avant
d'entrer dans le bain".
On les laisse, on rentre dans le bain, et là, on arrive dans les bains typiques
japonais, où en fait, vous avez des bains d'eau chaude d'un côté en gros,
et vous avez des petites cabines de douche, des petits sièges avec des petits
pommots de douche pour se doucher.
C'est très important, mais il faut se laver avant d'aller dans le bain, bien
évidemment pour que ce soit hygiénique, pour que l'hygiène soit bonne,
il faut se laver avant d'entrer dans le bain, comment ?
Et du coup, on a commencé, voilà, à se doucher, je pense qu'on s'est trop
nettoyés, on avait un peu peur de ne pas assez se laver,
du coup, on s'est lavé deux fois pour être sûr que ce soit ok avec les japonais,
et après, on a pu profiter du bain.
Il y avait un bain d'eau chaude, un bain avec des bulles, il y avait un bain
d'eau froide, parce que quand on reste trop longtemps dans l'eau chaude,
on peut avoir la tête qui tourne, donc on a alterné, on faisait bain à eau
chaude, un peu de bain d'eau froide,
et il y avait aussi quelque chose d'assez spécifique, qui est un bain
électrique.
Apparemment, c'est quitte ou double, soit on aime, soit on n'aime pas, j'ai
essayé, j'ai pas trop aimé.
En gros, c'est vous rentrez dans l'eau et il y a des coups d'électricité, donc
c'est bizarre, vous avez l'impression que ça vous pique.
Et donc, bon, c'était pas très agréable.
Mais du coup, voilà, on s'est retrouvé dans un bain, on a profité, c'était
vraiment super agréable,
et après, on est ressortis, on s'est séchés, on s'est rabillés, on est repartis,
et l'expérience était hyper agréable.
Et une fois qu'on l'avait fait une première fois, forcément, ça nous semble
beaucoup plus simple,
ça nous semble moins compliqué, on se fait moins de nœud au cerveau pour aller
dans ce genre de bâtiments.
Mais quand j'étais un an au Japon, je me rappelle que des fois, je me suis
retrouvé à nouveau tout seul, le seul blanc, dans un bain avec 30 Japonais, et
c'était toujours aussi impressionnant.
c'est marqué sur ma tête que je suis un étranger, donc c'était impressionnant.
Par contre, plusieurs fois, assis dans un bain, il y a les vieux du quartier qui
ont commencé à me parler.
Pareil dans le sauna, à un moment, j'ai eu une personne qui a commencé à me
parler en anglais, je lui ai dit je parle un peu japonais, on a commencé à
parler en japonais.
Donc c'est vraiment marrant parce qu'on est tout nus, et on commence à parler
avec des inconnus, c'est vraiment marrant.
Et d'ailleurs, dans le sauna, au bout d'un moment, je lui ai dit je dois arrêter
la conversation parce que là j'ai trop chaud, je vais tomber dans les pommes si
je reste, et voilà, c'était pour la petite histoire.
Mais du coup, c'est vrai qu'une fois qu'on passe un peu ce cap de la pudeur
physique, on va dire, l'expérience devient vraiment cool.
Et du coup, si jamais vous allez au Japon, n'hésitez pas à essayer les bains
publics, demandez bien à l'accueil si les tatouages sont acceptés, si vous en
avez, parce que ce n'est pas vraiment accepté au Japon encore, donc il est
préférable de demander avant d'entrer dans le bain.
Regardez un peu les règles sur internet. Si possible, essayer peut-être, ouais,
j'allais dire peut-être essayer un bain un peu touristique où il y a beaucoup de
touristes parce que souvent il y a des explications en anglais.
Par exemple, la fois où on était à Kagoshima, donc la ville tout au sud de
Kyushu, il n'y avait aucune explication en anglais, tout était en japonais, et
il fallait se débrouiller.
Donc voilà, c'était juste pour vous partager cette expérience. Je n'avais pas du
tout de script, j'espère que ce n'était pas trop brouillon.
J'espère que ça vous a plu. Si vous avez aimé ce genre d'anecdotes,
n'hésitez
pas à me le dire, je pourrais faire d'autres vidéos sur ce genre de sujet.
Également, j'ai créé un Patreon si vous voulez me soutenir dans cette aventure
sur ces créations de vidéos. Pour l'instant, je gagne ma vie avec mes cours de
français.
La création de vidéo, ça me plaît, ça me prend du temps et je ne gagne pas
vraiment d'argent avec, donc c'est un moyen de me soutenir.
En contrepartie, j'ai créé un Discord qui sera accessible seulement pour les
personnes du Patreon. Il y aura une Q&A ou des vidéos "behind the stage" sur le
Patreon, il y aura un peu de contenus exclusifs.
Et il y avait une dernière chose. Je mettrai aussi les remerciements en fin de
vidéo YouTube. Si vous voulez me soutenir, n'hésitez pas à aller voir le
Patreon, il y aura le lien dans la description.
Merci d'avoir regardé jusqu'au bout et je vous dis à la prochaine.